who's this bivo guy beus
Brandon I got sent this stuff the other
day or
today and uh the guy
is
a you it says you know the rules who is
thisy oh man deser Vivo Ed Matthews you
know the rules man no come on dude these
are the most British guys of all time
these guys couldn't look more British
then the the bivo guy I'm assuming bivo
is the one with the goatee
because of his face and that's who would
be called
bivo they got the S6 Bo one B what we
not one B we have to do two but what we
got here we got brownie Brownie and ice
cream yeah yeah this is from georan
Dragon big up to georan dragon georan
dragon well this this right this out of
yeah we got the brownie okay stop saying
big up to brownie first of all and you
didn't even eat it yet you know fumbling
with it so hard and big up well you say
big up after you eat it huh got Ed
Matthews got the
boxing nice oh banging that went down
the G well come back on camera I don't
do two
t dude first of all oh my God come up
come back on camera I downed two takes
the
eag oh my God come in camera go on what
were you writing it out of 10 that is
banging B that nice with your ice cream
goes
well no it's very Che how to get down
the car bro bro hey hey hey guy hey guy
laughing it's not funny to
eat I can't stop laughing cuz it tastes
good the dumbest guy
alive oh [__] my day SP is going man I'm
abely losing
it yeah you need to treat it twice
anyway I'm not guessing that is nice
that is very nice big up sticky is itat
and tend treat treat me to a nice
dessert Pi up the RO cheers yeah come
[Laughter]
on I don't Che a lot that's just me is
it let's finish it off in hour right you
oh no dude there's a minute more of this
listen dinner Ed Matthew's bivo I'm
treating him to a chip shop Saturday sa
chips you know the rules big up oh dude
the first one he was wearing a Burberry
shirt and this one he's wearing a Jon
shirt and it's so awesome and the other
guy's there and he's already about to
laugh and he's got a hot dog and [__]
french fries you know don't have to
review it um yeah have you had to S
before n bro first time first time what
we trying this year go now you
know sweet dude British people will
start will start the conversation in the
middle of the conversation you know
straight up this is how a British
conversation starts oh what we doing now
then isn't it what what we doing now
then what were we deciding
something what we doing now a
it
Che
hey what's the thing he's doing before
he eats it for the first time Che
cheers dude this guy looks honestly like
a backstory boy with a filter on his
face bro why is it funny to
eat why is Flavor [__] gut-bustingly
hilarious banging I've got the ketchup
pick up the ketchup you know the rules
me a bit what is the what are the
rules big up to ketchup you know the
rules dude imagine being a person that
says big up to
ketchup you know what I'm saying
man it's
sauce ketchup don't care if you big it
up or
not you want some all over yeah I'm
teaching him well
all over yeah I'm teaching them well wow
dude I wonder if they're aware of what
they're saying
honestly that I'm still cheering he's
still cheering he's
slacking oh there bang you know
anchoring chips s eight out of 10 got
the one punch bag one punch bag with the
mozzarella sticks in this have one each
yeah what you write the
sub free m fre you don't like subway
what real stick bit
ketchup in one mate with
that every time it's got eaty left
that's F why is that funny that's why
that's nice
that's bro these guys are incred
rible okay I'm going to watch another
one dinner you know the rules big up the
hang over beef roast dinner beef
whatever listen we got beef uh they are
what they are P blankets we got a Yi
pudding peas potatoes parsnips or so
British dude we've got peas potatoes
we've got a weird hat someone might wear
and uh we've got a guy with bad breath
here we go we know the rules pick up
brussel sprouts but split up so
British and a tomato for no reason just
over here in me pocket all right here we
go this you know the rules as well
Jamaican Star big up the Levi Roots
thing actually rate this and we got none
left so I'm going have to go to the shop
Levi sort your man out s me doesn't even
have enough you know just all the way at
the bottom I should have left it upside
down anyway we go is it
doesn't have enough
dude get sweet all right let's get in s
just right everything out of 10 uh
whatever that is I keep forgetting
brussel
sprout I've seasoned very well this
guy's a
chipmunk very dude the
way he
swallows and his hair
shakes and he's like
this [__] in the back of his throat you
know right
here very nice they cut up they're
banging uh seven out of 10 pig in
blanket sorry aie again you know the
rules dude the way he swallowing
man I wish I could hang out with this
guy but this is season very well big up
the personal shift aka the dad seven out
of 10 on that uh beef well that's not
that good dude seven out of 10 is not
good that's just absolutely mental it's
amazing wow [__] big up man this is so
[__] unbelievable let's give it a
free oh look at this this are good oh
look at this big up still made this this
a [__] unbelievable ah let's give it
a four let's put a sauce on it make it
better ah it's so much better with the
sauce on it all right let's give it a
two let's give that with a two you put
the SAU It's [__] amazing is it it's
a four and then you put the sauce on it
ah now it's a one that's amazing put
more sauce on it let's just try and chew
this what do you mean let's just try and
chew this what do you
mean just beef hanging out of his mouth
dude hey dude get rid of the mic you
know
ew just so just got out of the shower
too what dude the
way
I can spend a whole episode on this
[__] mad Cherry mad Cherry still
nice 7 out of
10 come come on come on
dude I know you're laughing at home oh
it's [__] mad nice the way he Che
like just SW like oh it's [__] too
chewy is it mate ah [__] seven out of
10 looking well York [__] we're g to rip
a bit off this [__] looks so bad
honestly honestly this plate looks
abhorent it looks so it's a travesty
it's so gross dude if you're at your
friend's house and they brought this out
You' be like oh [__] I should have not
stayed over for
dinner standard Jes here s out of 10 TI
Go Go bro you got to be [__] kidding
me
let's get right into that no another
thing I mean didn't chew that one very
seasoned very nice seven out of 10 I
think that's it
bro no
creativity I
mean oh pnip oh pnip let me guess let me
guess let me
guess
big up listen big up The Hangover beef
dinner overall no give it an eight I'm
know right dude everything was a seven
he G it an
eight seven but
what big up Pang
over big up the8 out on the dinner G to
go live make sure come over catch in the
next one
Che how is this guy real oh I love this
guy
Chee hold on let's look at oh Egypt
lunch W this guy travels how many
followers you have oh he has a million
point1
followers let's see what we got B oh
Burger King all right let's
see lunch you know the rules this we got
a warart we got chips it comes a lot of
money it was dear I think it's like £10
for a mill it's very CL but look at that
last time I broke it was in Turkey so
big up Burger King Big up the Turks big
up shoing on New Year's Day big up your
New Year we should hit a mill as well so
big up the midi let's get into
it I mean dude it's just Burger
King not
bad not bad I like the slame grilled
slame grilled cooking is good why does
he swallow like that his hair bounces so
much when he
swallows
not bad not bad s out of 10 chips
bro that guy's amazing seven out of
10 well I mean you can't argue with it
right what a great guy on the internet